the Joe Rogan experience did you ever
watch the video where Trump was on the
WWE have you ever seen that yeah we
bought it because you love it for
tweeting but it's us it's so strange to
think that the current president used to
be on the WWE was on an episode of the
WWE he was in a match he well okay he
would--he pardon lagoa [ __ ] the former
host of a game show just became
president and pardon one of his former
contestant yes till it's a dick would
read that go yeah I'm done good night
cancer hurry up and I'm done I don't
know it's so strange it's so strange all
of it so strange almost my most
conspiratorial thoughts are that this is
this is AI and that AI is slowly
bringing us deeper and deeper into into
the the hive into the matrix and the way
they're doing it is by disconnecting us
from each other making social distancing
the norm cover your face with the mask
don't touch anything everything you're
gonna do virtually and slowly but surely
it's gonna lead to this new way of life
where you're you're you're no longer at
risk by going out there and making
yourself susceptible to all these
biological nasties you're gonna stay
home you're gonna plug in or what if the
AI knows that eventually it does have to
unplug us and let us see that we're in
the protein pods looks like that's gonna
freak them out now let's make this fake
reality so [ __ ] insane and awful will
have Trumpy president will have this
virus so that we do unplugged in those
oh thank god okay good fine I'm okay
with I'm cool being in the protein pod
good like actually they're making it so
that will be happy when were shown that
we're living in roasting pot a slant at
least there's order in the universe and
it's not just completely ridiculous I
mean I've had those arguments with
people about there's a there's a very
strong case to be made for ciphers
character in the matrix of like no plug
me the [ __ ] back into this anyone know
I'm nude with no muscles atrophied
hairless in a jagged wasteland of
radioactive slag or I could be in this
world where I have a nice job and I eat
a steak and marry someone and I just
live in this I'm fine with it
like Morpheus who the [ __ ] you
helping dragging ass at me the machines
aren't trying to kill us they're just
like look you guys and watch by the way
the machines like you guys [ __ ] up the
earth we're doing the best we can for
you guys we could have just let you all
die in a wasteland but instead we found
a way so that you can play the machine
for doing anything that nefarious right
right they're just letting you have a
better existence than your real one it's
indistinguishable it's also it feels it
feels better it actually does people
always miss that line where Smith says
you know when we first did the matrix it
was just flat-out paradise and you guys
couldn't handle that and you rejected it
like we literally had you we're probably
the first birds in the matrix everybody
could fly and orgasms lasted three
months and you could just eat all the
chocolate you wanted and they people
like no and then I want a goddamn
cubicle job for them I guess they want
cubicle define okay give them that I we
tried to be nice
[Applause]